guten Morgen Frau Yali sie haben
angekündigt sobald wie möglich eine
Entscheidung fällen zu wollen die
Ukraine kann und will nicht mehr warten
Ihre Ansage ist vier Tage alt wird
Deutschland also jetzt Leopard 2 Panzer
liefern ja oder nein
diese Antwort kann ich nicht geben ich
habe immer wieder darauf hingewiesen sie
eben in ihrem Beitrag auch diese
Entscheidung fällt im Kanzleramt was ich
gemacht habe und das Ergebnis liegt in
Kürze jetzt vor ist eine präzise
Aufstellung zu machen welche Typen
welchen Leopards mit welchen anderen
zusammen zu Verbänden
zusammengeschlossen werden können weil
das ist die Voraussetzung dafür dass
wenn ein Jahr kommt was möglicherweise
in den nächsten Tagen der Fall sein wird
dass wir dann auch schnell
handlungsfähig sind ausbilden können und
die Verbände dann auch entsprechend
verlegen können aber dieses Argument
kommt ja oft nachschubketten wir müssen
gucken haben wir ausreichend Munition
Einrichtung von Reparaturwerkstätten
industriepotenziale und so weiter das
hätten sie oder Deutschland doch schon
lange im Blick haben müssen der
Angriffskrieg dauert ein Jahr
ja die Frage ist ja worauf bereitet man
sich vor wir haben ich habe meinerseits
alles getan was getan werden konnte ich
verfolge Diskussion sehr aufmerksam
natürlich verstehe die Sorgen und die
Ängste der ukrainischen Freunde ich
teile sie und nichtsdestotrotz hat
Deutschland hier eine besondere
Verantwortung und Rolle gerade weil es
die leopardenaktion ist und wie sie
schon sagt ich treffe gleich den
Generalsekretär der NATO und da geht's
dann um die Frage einerseits die
Voraussetzungen weiter aufrecht zu
erhalten für Abschreckung und
Verteidigung also die
bündnisverteidigung sicherzustellen und
gleichzeitig die Ukraine zu unterstützen
und beides geht nur dann wenn
entsprechendes Material aus dem aus den
Armenien Europas zusammengestellt wird
dass dann dort fehlt aber dort schnell
ersetzt war werden muss das leuchtet
glaube ich jedem ein und das sind die
Voraussetzungen die geschaffen werden
müssen sonst sind wir anstellen blank
will ich mal salopp sagen an denen wir
es nicht sein sollten im Hinblick auf
Bündnis und Landesverteidigung und
welche Stellen sind das konkret weil im
Moment findet der Krieg auf ukrainischen
Territorium statt und selten hat der
Kanzler gesagt dort wird auch unsere
Freiheit verteidigt also müssten sie
doch im Grunde das was wir haben wenn
sie dann fertig gezählt haben sowohl aus
Deutschland heraus aber auch den
Partnern erlauben die Panzer dorthin zu
schicken also worauf konkret warten sie
so richtig verstehen tue ich es nicht
das verstehe ich wiederum der Kanzler
führt die entsprechenden Gespräche ich
wiederhole noch mal das ist nicht meine
Entscheidung ich bereite mich auf eine
mögliche Entscheidung vor die die
Verlegung von Leopard Panzer und die
Zustimmung an andere europäische und
natropartner das zu tun zu erteilen ich
war bereite mich darauf vor alles andere
muss ich selber auch abwarten wer
Führung bestellt bekommt sie auch das
hat der Kanzler gesagt und auch im neuen
Eckpunktepapier der Kanzler Partei ihrer
Partei der SPD steht Deutschland müsste
eine stärkere Führungsrolle übernehmen
das tut Deutschland aktuell aber nicht
Polen sagt dazu inakzeptabel und den
Polen geht die Geduld aus und sagen wir
werden jetzt diesen Antrag stellen und
zur Not machen wir es vielleicht auch
einfach in einer kleinen Koalition
Annalena bärbock die Außenministerin
sagte am Wochenende okay dann ist das so
wir stellen uns dem nicht in den Weg ist
das so
das hörte sich ja dann gestern in
Brüssel schon wieder ein klein wenig
anders an wenn ich das richtig gehört
habe aber ungeachtet dessen will ich
noch mal darauf hinweisen es ist nicht
so wie so geriert wird dass alle Partner
in Europa hier einer Meinung sein das
ist ein Rammstein sehr deutlich geworden
es geht kein Riss durch das Bündnis es
gibt die eine Gruppe die sagt wir müssen
das vorsichtig abwägen und genau
überlegen was wir tun was wir tun können
und die anderen die vorweg marschieren
wollen und lassen Sie mich noch eins
sagen Führung zu übernehmen heißt nicht
blind voran zu laufen und alle anderen
hinter sich herzuziehen sondern Führung
heißt immer auch Verantwortung für das
was gemeinsam passiert und dieser
Verantwortung wird der Kanzler gerecht
und wenn die Entscheidung dann noch ein
zwei Tage dauert dann ist das eben so
Klärung und Abstimmung das kaschiert
irgendwie das wahre Problem nämlich dass
der Kanzler nicht wirklich erklärt was
er will oder was er nicht will und
deshalb sagen jetzt mittlerweile nicht
wenige vor allen Dingen die baltischen
Staaten und die osteuropäischen
Deutschland zögern das sei eigentlich
der Alleingang und Putin könnte sich
möglicherweise darüber freuen denn eine
Spaltung Europas wird gerade auf offener
Bühne zur Schau getragen ist das im
Sinne Deutschlands
es kann nicht im Sinne Deutschland sein
das kann auch nicht im Sinne der NATO
sein das kann vor allen Dingen auch
nicht im Sinne der osteuropäischen
Nato-Partner sein ich verstehe deren
Position sehr sehr gut in ihrer
exponierten Lage gegenüber Russland aber
noch mal wir sind alle gut beraten diese
vermeintliche Spaltung innerhalb der
NATO nicht mutwillig herbeizureden es
gibt kein Alleingang Deutschlands und es
sollte kein Alleingang von anderen geben
wir sind ein Bündnis und so sollten wir
auch agieren ich glaube das leuchtet
jedem ein ja aber Großbritannien sagt ja
sie werden möglicherweise Panzer
schicken die Amerikaner denken auch
darüber nach also das mit dem Alleingang
ist irgendwie so ein hingelegtes
Argument kann das vielleicht sein dass
es einfach gar keine richtige Strategie
gibt dass Deutschland oder aber auch die
Verbündeten nicht so richtig wissen was
das Ziel ist denn wenn man das wüsste
dann müsste man auch wissen welche
Waffen welche Panzer man schickt haben
sie ein Konzept
ja natürlich haben wir ein Konzept und
es gibt auch eine Strategie und ein Wort
zu den Amerikanern die Amerikaner
liefern Bradley Schützenpanzer Abraham
sind nicht im Gespräch bei den
Engländern handelt sich meines Wissens
um 13 oder 14 Challenger das ist doch
kein Game changer im Krieg in der
Ukraine von daher auch genau daran wird
deutlich es macht keinen Sinn wenn jeder
sagt ich will jetzt dieses oder jenes
machen es muss abgestimmt passieren und
darauf drängt der Kanzler er hat nie
gesagt dass er nie bereit sein wird
seine Zustimmung zu erteilen es geht
darum dass abgestimmt zu tun und der
Wunsch nach Abstimmung ist nicht das
gleiche wie ein Alleingang und das
Konzept ist dann am Ende die Ukraine in
ihrem Ziel zu unterstützen das ganze
Land zu verteidigen und wieder zurück
auf die Grenzen von 2014 unterstützt
Deutschland die Ukraine da drin
wir unterstützen die Ukraine diesen
Krieg nicht zu verlieren ihnen zu
gewinnen gegenüber gegen Russland und
dazu tut Deutschland mehr als praktisch
jede andere Bündnispartner außer den USA
wir haben alleine mit dem frühlingspaket
was wir jetzt auf den Weg gebracht haben
mit 40 Mördern brückenlege Panzern
Patrick System und vielem andere mehr
1,1 Milliarden Euro aufgewendet zusammen
mit dem was vorher bereits passiert ist
reden wir bereits über 3,3 Milliarden
Euro Großbritannien bewegt sich etwa in
der gleichen Liga alle anderen sind
weiter hinter also Deutschland muss ich
wirklich nicht verstecken aber wir
machen das eben ausgewogen und trotzdem
sehr zielgerichtet sagt der neue
Verteidigungsminister vielen Dank Boris
Pistorius für ihre Zeit und jetzt ein
gutes Gespräch mit dem
National bis bald